let's bring in Charles Barkley do you
like this argument Chuck I don't think
it's that big of a deal I mean I think
all those teams you name the wars the
probably would come in fourth place I
mean they got a very good team don't get
me wrong but listen the best four teams
I've played against were bull bird
Celtics magic Lakers 1 1 and 1 8 and
Michael Bulls were 3 but that's not
listen it ain't old guys hey no young
guys you know this this team almost lost
Oklahoma City you think any of those
teams could lose to Oklahoma City or be
down 3-1
hell no if you play by today's rules
though with Whitney you're not allowed
to put your hands on anybody and the
3-point shot does is that the great
equalizer here it with the you know the
Warriors now against these other teams
would be alright couldn't touch him
as great as Michael Lewis with Michaels
Dennis Rodman Scottie Pippen Ron Harper
20 cuckoos which they would be great to
be I still don't think they were good as
bird septic and I imagine Lakers now
what about the Pistons the bad boys
where would you rank that team I think
that they would be today's warriors I
think Isiah and Joe Dumars would match
up great with clay and stealth and I
think Dennis Rodman would do great they
could never keep him off the board I
only want to talk about lamb beer and
John Salley and those guys I mean people
get because we live in the moment
Laura's got a terrific team let's be
realistic they would not put a lot of
fear in our heart back in the day you
also talked you were early in on a jump
shooting team not being able to win the
championship I think last year you
talked about that have you I mean is
your is your feelings different about
the jump shot the three-point shot and
being able to be a great team
sustainable
what I said about the tea master glass I
said they were in a championship this
year I will take back everything I said
last year about a jump shooting team you
know last year they got a favorable
results with all the injuries but I said
I've said that if they win the
championship this year I have to pay I
had to say I was wrong which I have no
problem saying that because uh but I
will say this they got a much better
[ __ ] and they played great defense they
are jump shooting team but I
underestimated their bench and I
underestimated estimated their defense
but they got a really good team and I
have no problem saying I was wrong
it's and I've said that if I get if they
win a challenge if I get them on these
that is one of the best things I've seen
all right if you're looking at the end
result you're golden state if they go
back-to-back they're gonna be one of the
great teams of all time
but what happens to Cleveland and
Cleveland loses what do we do you see
things changing on the roster with
probably got a good team they just
listen they got a good team they're just
fine against the team maybe I have a
listen this theory is not over yet
everybody's wrote this there is this to
resolve let's see what happened next
couple games before we hand awards the
championship main you got it we made
this mistake last thing is when we
handed the series to Oklahoma City when
they blew out the Warriors in games
three and four so let's see how this
series plays out you know the thing is
gonna be funny
you know the BS other media as I call it
I told one of my friends you were
drinking wine last week I said you know
the fans are so stupid they don't get to
trick of sports as after this theory
there's gonna be a or beat the Warriors
will over eat it or LeBron loses again
in the finals they're never gonna give
anybody credit we have to blame somebody
but that best was just gonna be the
funny thing I call it a BS of sports I
mean the fans are so stupid they don't
wander standard tricks how sports works
I think I said it's gonna be a or b the
Warriors are overrated or LeBron lose
again in the finals and steadily given
one of these teams credit he's Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer joining us Dan
Patrick show I'm curious what you think
about the NBA with this
transparency that they're going to
continue to sort of give you the
scorecard of when they miss calls in the
final two minutes the the official said
you know that why are we doing this this
isn't fair they don't want that out
there this transparency where do you
weigh in I think it's one of the
stupidest things the NBA's ever that
hang there definitely is out to dry you
know damn referees are gonna miss them
calls because of technology tough
slow-mo slow-mo slow-mo and HD
televisions they're gonna miss them
cause they've always missed calls but
they are really out there doing a
fantastic job I mean but III I'm not I
don't understand what the NBA is doing
trying to hang these guys out to dry I
mean I think they need to mix that
immediately first of all if they want to
be transparent that's something that's
called in the first quarter I agree but
I don't understand why do you hang these
officials out to dry in the last two
minutes like I say just because a fan
I've never gotten a call wrong in slow
motion you do know that right if I could
sit at home and look at it five times in
slow motion I'm not gonna miss a call
either but when you've got ten guys out
there like think about a last round
against Oklahoma City we came in to rent
out there you've got four seven-foot
guys at one point when I got Ibaka Adams
and those guys out there in Kanter the
referees are gonna miss him calls but
what majority call they do a fantastic
job i commended you when Game six
Oklahoma City at a halftime you said
what needed to be said about Kevin
Durant but this is what makes you great
is you know what I think
Ernie and Shaq and Kenny were kind of
dancing around Kevin Durant's
performance and you said no he's
terrible he's playing that selfish hero
ball and you know I wanted to say it to
you personally I thought it was you said
what needed to be said and it didn't
take you long to get to the point well
then I think you know me I'm not always
gonna be fair I'm always gonna be honest
I think that's why people some people
like me and some people hate me but they
know I don't please say this I don't
play favorites at all I think that's one
reason I don't like reporters
because they play favorites our job is
to be fair the people deserve a fair
opinion came in to rent a hell of a
player and the thing that frustrated me
the most about that serious love they
beat the Spurs and they go up 3-1 on the
Warriors playing great team basketball
and then all of a sudden they want to be
the guy who'll get carried off it with
this you get carried off on their
shoulders you know if you go back and
look they were one of the worst teams
assist wise in the NBA during the
regular season and the postseason they
were one of the better team and they got
them to the Conference Finals about 3:1
then all of a sudden you know then I
tell people all time Michael Jordan
didn't make every big shot I mean Axl
made the to the 3-pointer beat up in the
finals Steve Kerr made some big shot
against the Jazz I mean the great player
don't always have to make the last shot
and you know when we lost to the Rockets
in game still Mario Elie made the shot
to fit them to the finals yeah and I
think that but the best team in the NBA
that's nice it's Oklahoma City Thunder
nobody has more talent than old guys but
they reverted back to hero ball and it
cost them the championship because they
got a better team than the Warriors and
this play and the Cavaliers but they
don't they don't pass the ball enough to
each other I don't trust the other guys
yeah and they got a regret bullying that
3-1 League because depending on what
happens with Kevin and well for the next
couple of years they could have had a
nice little window where they could have
won several championships
now I commended you on your broadcasting
style but I have to be critical in your
baseball style the baseball swing oh did
you play baseball growing up well no I
think it was Chris Brown's bat a shooter
grab Rizzo's bat did you play totally
did you play Little League I played in a
little league a little bit but let me
just tell you something baseball is not
my strong suit
but you know what it's fun to play bass
I like I've taken batting practice a
couple times it's just some fun to do
and the Cubs and a Phillies were great
they're my two favourite teams i root by
the Phillies I do I root for the
Phillies but I love Chicago and Toronto
my two favorite City so I root for those
two teams in baseball but it was fun to
do it was really I loved it man I love
to take advantage before I let you go
how much did Muhammad Ali mold your
personality or am i is it a reach for me
to connect the two I did think of you
when we looked at all of those old clips
with Ollie not that you were that kind
of showman when you were playing like
you weren't guaranteeing wins and
calling out Jordan and those kind of
things but I think now as an analyst I
see a little bit more of Muhammad Ali's
frankness well bad yeah I think people
close to me I got a real nice text from
Kenny I think Muhammad leads the most
important person in my life as far as
trying to when you get to be Who I am I
want to always stand up for poor people
and that's my number one objective to
speak out on social issues and he's
always been the most important
significant person in my life and every
time I got a chance to see him I told
him that you know I never want to just
be rich and famous I got lucky to be
able to play basketball and I do many it
hurt me it hurts me a lot you know I
always tell people I roll models of
Muhammad Ali dr. Martin Luther King and
Bill Russell and all of them you know I
never talked about black and white
because there's just as many white
people out there struggling like black
people has always been white people in
the civil rights struggle but man it
hurt me probably says my grandmother
who's the father second most the most
important person in my life it just hurt
me and I was fortunate enough that I got
a chance to tell my hamat several times
how much he meant to me and it's just it
was just hard it was
even though I knew the end was comin it
still hurt and anytime you know like
I've been trying to get the NBA to move
the all-star game out of Charlotte
because of the transgender thing and you
know it's up to me you know all these
guys talk about money and Championships
and think like a man it'd be great to
win a chance to be great to help money
but when you're rich and famous
especially if you're black expensive
you're black I feel like I have an
obligation to talk about the state of
education in this country with setting
all these black kids these poor high
schools and not making them successful
and things like that
I'm gonna use my puppet to try to help
poor people but this is the clothes man
Ali meant the world to me and I can
never thank him and Bill Russell and dr.
King and you know Jim Brown even though
Jim Brown has been hard on some of us
we're trying you know we're tryin and
there's no way I can ever compare myself
so I'll leave because I've never been
through anything like a struggle like
that I've never been through anything
hard in my life and I do know racism
exist and I do know economic situations
the rich and the poor it's a tough
situation but it was just a horror
weekend for me there and I appreciate
you asking me that question will you
consider boycotting the all-star game
yes but but you know and I have said it
and I've told my boss I don't want to
act like I'm jumping on a sword but I
talked to Adam said we need to move the
all-star game I'm definitely but I like
I said I don't want to act like you know
I only bought their crying wolf I hope
they don't put me in a situation where I
have to boycott the altar again we need
to move the all-star game and I said
that but yeah I will consider that oh
it's great catching up with you chuck
and I appreciate the Muhammad Ali
comments as well thanks for joining us
okay may I get them there's a rage too
badly they not drifting the best I'll
give them a raise of thumb why don't you
take that up as one of your causes there
Chuck yeah you can't just hog all the
money if you got your name on the show
good to say goodbye to you right now
Chuck thanks for joining us all right
man thanks for having me you guys have a
great week
all right and that's Charles Barkley the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience